keine ahnung was schief glaube einer
verfolgten
ceausescus und willkommen zu einer neuen
heute mit dem genau und ich würde sagen
wir machen einen kurzen krone wieder auf
und komme fakt mich ziemlich ab aber
erst mal gucken wie das kit wird spielen
ich bin das känguru kit das massaker
jetzt darum dazu warum gar nicht abfragt
erstens die rundenzeiten auf 30 sekunden
verkürzt heißt man muss seine ansagen
immer draus machen wenn man mal rein
dort kann man dann noch häufiger kein
kind mehr auswählen und generell sowie
games funktion irgendwie überhaupt nicht
da musste ich jetzt echt mal kritik
aussprechen am golm hd team diese server
restart mit dem kompletten umbau den er
hat mir nicht gefallen ganz ehrlich
sicher arbeitet jedoch dran und werden
das verbessern aber bis jetzt muss ich
sagen - auf jeden fall
trotzdem werfen wir einen blick in die
steps - so platz 63 65 ist erreicht das
heißt die folgerung kommen und jetzt
investieren du bist so ein kleiner -
honda die folge nee ich bin bis im plus
ich bin plus oder minus quadrat
denn an den quadrant wird seien etwa 325
67 okay wir schaffen ja wahrscheinlich
ne das wasser türkis gemerkt dass
diensten am ende war war der countdown
überhaupt nicht mehr rhythmisch da war
einfach so ein scheiß war einfach so 32
fast glaubt ihr waren uns verarschen da
die reiter
sie sind lustig drauf welche leute
besser drauf ist egal wer sich draussen
ist denke ich hier ist mehr lustig was
hat es gemacht mädchen hat für mich war
klar was machst du gerade mädchen gesagt
und gesagt dass goma hd team denkt es
wäre lustig weil es den rhythmus ändert
das kann ich auch so einer gemacht wurde
ist holen aber das hat nicht
funktioniert
beziehungsweise seid doch funktioniert
weil wir am anfang relativ wenig wert
bekommen haben jetzt damit trotzdem acht
gold acht reisen
scheiße es gut mal nicht sondern ich bin
spiel und achtet das reicht schon aus
fischers ok
ja das ist die scheiße so zu sagen okay
was klar aus wie immer soja auf drei
wogen auf zwei und dann geht's auf die
hand soll gleich vorbei sein die
wartezeit wir auch schon 13 dingsbums
noch einer perle okay gewesen hätten das
bist du heute warte ich hätte ich gerne
drauf ich glaube jetzt habe ich die
gerade so ein bisschen zu tisch kann es
sein hat er dich erwischt nö ich bin der
spion
du hast ja für unsichtbare smarter typ
ich kann mir nicht helfen
achtung bei hausgeburten nehme ich nicht
riskieren wollte habe ihr dabei nicht
treffen guckt euch das an leute was habt
ihr das gesehen habt ihr das gesehen ich
war ein block hinter dem konnte nicht
treffen
junge junge was war das wir die
kommentare ich registriert schon wieder
nach hacks hier ist richtig dass herr
kollege jetzt habe ich dich hab ich
jetzt was gar nicht daneben
das deckt sich gerade wieder eine hoch
nutze im vancouver geschafft
in dem moment wieder schafft und mein
handy meldet sich mal wieder so sehr gut
ich das einfach mal jetzt gerade gerade
kurz die oder einfach mit in der ems
ohne handy mieten ist kein ding da dies
kein tierfreund ist der nächste gegner
jetzt sind aber gut und wollen hier die
sind echt gut
ob es du das nie ich bin da um auf den
turm war ich wieder weil wieder lustig
war
chancen sehen im chat liegen weil ich
weiß nicht ob damit nicht gebaut wird
ganz oben auf dem ding
hast du dich hoch gebaut nein ich habe
mich nicht hoch gebaut aber hass und
wasser einmal dabei immer dabei was
meinst du hast dann habe ich nicht ich
wer direkt wieder angezündet angezündet
alles klar passt jetzt kann weitermachen
es ist ein richtiger der bastard känguru
ist ziemlich sauber das känguru
regelmäßig oder
ich war eben häufig auch erzählt und
wurde dann von bastad ruhig gegen dich
nicht einmal hatte ich noch ein
spielende hand in hand gesehen nicht
geknallt
ohne etwas von uns hohmeister wieder
freigelegt hat der muss sich gelegt
alter tiki taka barroso jetzt aber nur
nicht jeder mieter und ich spiele mit
handicap ehrlich gesagt jsc eic mai was
geht ab alles klar
heute alle störgeräusche weil und der
extra für euch keiner angerufen aber ich
ende mal kurz mal schreibt statt das
auch beschäftigt jo mein handy wieder
hier in der mail die zentrale vom
frankfurter flughafen
da ist geld ab ok keine ahnung keine
ahnung ich habe keine ahnung einfach
keine ahnung aber der geht nächste
gegner ist ein bisschen weit entfernt
deswegen können wir uns mal hier eine
leggins braucht mir glaube ich sollte ja
das war jetzt echt ziemlich ziemlich
groß schön viele kills in richtig kurzer
zeit haben eigentlich erfahrungs
fläschchen nein wir können nicht
verzaubern
ok erwarte jetzt unter die 8
okay ich bin gerade nicht im raid modus
ist es ein känguru erstmal alles ging
echt egal wir jetzt auch mal drauf heute
einfach mal solo modus anmachen
aktivieren glaubt er macht die marke
werden da nicht lebend rauskommen jetzt
ging vier leute aber europe
komm ich verstehe es nicht man kann
einfach den vereinen die leute nicht
traden der gamescom mir viel viel
schwieriger vor als in kobe ein halb
herzen
ich bin richtig umgesprungen gerade das
wahrlich keine gute idee ich glaube
gleich passiert irgendwas passiert
irgendwas ihr müsst euch ihr müsst
verstehen das licht kommt von da also
von hinter der face kann habe ich mein
fenster auf und die sonne rein und mein
bildschirm ist als 30 dunkel ist es
immer nach den inder games deswegen sich
ungefähr gar nichts
also ich sehe wirklich zero gar nichts
wird das ist richtig richtig krass
gerade und ich glaube dass wichtige
peter hinten der typ aber es kann aber
aber es kann längere er ist kein känguru
und ich dachte aber passiert oder
gemacht
jonas war das war richtig los geht es
war der klassische es kennt von nrg es
dreieinhalb herzen und trotzdem auf dem
vollgepackten gegner gehen und es am
ende auch noch schaffen mal gehört was
war das der leute das war jetzt so hart
klick auf dem blog damit sie schneller
ja sagt nein ich kann kämpfen ich hasse
das mit speed zu kämpfen da treffe ich
gar nicht ich kann es überhaupt nicht ab
richtig gut ich hab euch mal vor zu hoch
geöffnet ist viel zu hoch ist die ganz
hat mich sozusagen die pfeile verdient
ja unfair r blockt die pfeile hatte ist
es der letzte
auf jeden fall der junge relativ viele
fähren in seinem namen und ich hasse es
die ganze drohte euro ist
schweinefleisch zu essen das ist so
nervig das ist so nervig einfach weil er
die ganze zeit jetzt kassierer rainer
bohnet
warum hat er so viel viel in seinem
namen keine ahnung ich glaube da ist
aber voll auf die vier hängen geblieben
keine anlässlich jungs schief glos ich
glaube einer verfolgt ich ja eh nicht
richtig leid
es gibt eine sache gibt
wir stellen alle kommt der wand der band
nee ich wollte seine sache am bett in
der jazzband man will der spielverderber
es macht dich fertig dafür ja
wahrscheinlich
jaja junger mensch ich wollte einfach
nur seine der sache haben und da kommt
zu nennen weil man auch immer das
schlechteste upmann optifast aufgibt bei
sowas
die runde war zehn minuten land kraft
das wird glaube ich die erste woche in
folge mit nur einer runde immer leute
ganz wichtig die kids in die kommentare
schreiben
ihr wisst bescheid das kann man der
letzten folge ein bisschen zu kurz diese
folge würde ich mich freuen wenn ein
bisschen mehr kids in den kommentaren
stehen last einen daumen nach oben da
und checkt die missgeburt in der
beschreibung ab dann sehen wir die
nächste folge wieder rein und